Al I love you so much we're getting
married so are you and Grand talking
anymore no his family on the other hand
I miss them hi you sweetie we're so
excited that you're coming for Christmas
I can't come home this year I'm sorry I
have a deadline you know what I think
this is about Ally because she ripped
out my heart stomped on it
okay
surprise Graham what are you doing here
I found all of these in the back CL what
are you doing here thought you said he
was working is that Ali shut up you're
kind of freaking out you invited my ex-
fiance to Christmas you know I really
should go you're not going anywhere I
have to get Mom and Dad to dump Ali
otherwise I'm going to be sharing my
family forever H oh my
God my family will work up the courage
to ask you to leave before Christmas
morning you want to bed then you're gone
well you're gone fam how do we feel
about a game night
tonight oh you were
fooled I think I'm done with game night
I had a feeling your competitive Spirit
might get into a little bit of trouble
he got to
[Music]
pee
coming no no no no no no where's the bu
does it have to be crazy this entire
holiday surrender anytime you want never
so either one of you dating yeah
everyone everyone yeah here's my number
between us girls not going to be a fun
night for
[Music]
you they pass aggressively hating each
other how about that I think that they
actually love each other it's quite
confusing times change and if you don't
change with them you're going to end up
marrying your own
hands show me what
I'm sorry I screwed up we both
[Music]
did hey your
bangs
it starting to realize where we went
wrong and I think that I can forgive
you what is wrong with her
son forever something for you right here
Graham oh hope it's not another
[Music]
X